[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat sur france 24 journée de deuil à
howald et au texas au lendemain de cette
tuerie dans une école primaire qui a
fait 21 victimes dont 19 enfants le
tireur âgé de 18 ans a été abattu par la
police de nationalité américaine il
aurait d'abord visé sa grand mère avant
de se rendre à l'école en voiture aurait
perpétré le massacre la maison blanche a
ordonné la mise en berne des drapeaux
dans tous les bâtiments publics
cette attaque replonge bien sûr les
états unis dans les affres des
fusillades en milieu scolaire elle
rappelle la tuerie de samedi rock dans
le connecticut en 2012 ou encore celle à
parkland en floride en 2018 joe biden a
réagi il est temps de transformer la
douleur en action a lancé le président
américain qui se rendra d'ailleurs sur
place ce week-end alors pourquoi malgré
les tueries le contrôle des armes ne
progresse t-il pas aux états unis le
deuxième amendement de la constitution
américaine et il sacré ce débat sa
visite il dans la campagne à quelques
mois des élections de mi mandat on
parlera aussi du texas en particulier où
la culture des arbres est
particulièrement forte et où le
gouverneur greg abbott et les sénateurs
jon corzine et ted cruz participe à la
convention de la nrpt et la national
rifle association à houston ce week-end
alors joe biden peut-il être celui qui
permettra une régulation des armes dans
le pays un contrôle des armes est il
impossible aux états unis on en débat
avec mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés à charlotte coquillon bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes chercheuse à l'ifri
institut français de géopolitique
journaliste spécialiste des états unis
bienvenue dans le débat en face de vous
alexandre modèle bon soir un journaliste
spécialiste des états unis auteurs de
chez trump 245 jours et 28 mille miles
dans cette amérique que les médias
junior et c'est aux éditions de
l'artilleur et vous publiez également un
certain nombre d'articles pour valeurs
actuelles nous allons avoir avec nous un
peu plus tard eric l'isan on espère
qu'on l'aura il sera en direct de
washington
ancien procureur fédéral
il est là éric bonsoir à vous et riklis
année bienvenue dans le débat vous êtes
donc en direct de washington
sabrina volta seul et une autre invitée
qui est un peu de retard donc on va
l'attendre l'arrivant et puis on va
avoir pierrick laurent bien sûr notre
envoyé spécial sur place a ouvert des au
texas le débat sur le contrôle des armes
vous savez qu'il divise la société
américaine les partisans de la vente
libre d'armes oppose un droit garanti
par la constitution
on fait tout de suite le premier en
images avec florent rothau
nous sommes en 1993 le président bill
clinton signe le breuil des actes
approuvé par le congrès il instaure la
vérification systématique des
antécédents psychiatriques et
judiciaires des acheteurs d'armes à feu
aux états unis mais dix ans plus tard le
congrès ne rejette pas cette loi sous
l'impulsion du républicain george bush
et de ses puissants alliés de la nrl le
lobby des armes
entre temps en 1999 la tuerie de
columbine vient rappeler aux américains
la réalité aucun autre pays au monde ne
connaît autant de fusillades que le leur
parmi les plus marquantes celle de sandy
hook en 2012 bilan 28 morts dont 20
enfants âgés de 6 et 7 ans les images
font le tour du monde l'émotion est vive
l'occasion pour le démocrate barack
obama de frapper fort en interdisant
notamment la vente de fusils d'assaut
mais quatre mois plus tard le congrès en
terre ses ambitions c'est une journée
assez honteuse pour washington mais je
veux être clair avec le peuple américain
nous pouvons encore changer les choses
et réduire la violence par armes à feu
en 2021 la chambre des représentants
vote une loi pour élargir les contrôles
mais le sénat la bloque le démocrate
chris murphy s'est lancé mardi dans un
vibrant plaidoyer
je suis ici pour mendier peg
ont littéralement me mettre à genoux et
supplier mes collègues trouver le chemin
suivre
al'inverse le républicain ted cruz
estime lui que les armes restent la
meilleure défense
l'outil le plus efficace pour assurer la
sécurité des enfants ce sont des forces
de l'anp d'armé sur le campus aux etats
unis la production d'armes à feu pour
les particuliers a explosé depuis 20 ans
elle a été multipliée par trois les
armes fantôme aussi sont de plus en plus
nombreuses faites maison elle ne possède
aucun numéro de série ce qui rend leur
traçage un possible début avril joe
biden a voulu s'attaquer au problème
mais sa marge de manoeuvre très réduite
au congrès l'en empêche pour l'instant
n'aurait-il et retrouver notre envoyé
spécial pyrite laurent à howald et au
texas pierrick bonsoir ou velde est en
deuil c'est l'émotion qui prime
aujourd'hui et que c'est ton un peu est
ce qu'on en sait un peu plus sur le
tueur
oui stéphanie on en sait un peu plus et
vous avez raison de dire c'est d'abord
l'émotion qui prime et les familles des
victimes veulent avoir évidemment des
éléments de réponse important sur ce qui
s'est passé on sait un peu plus sur la
façon dont la tuerie s'est déroulée on
sait que le jeune homme de 18 ans
salvador ramos était un lycéen ici de
cette ville ils étaient des scolarisés
depuis quelques mois il avait commencé à
travailler dans un restaurant de fast
food et donc il a été décidé de d'abord
tiré sur sa grand-mère et puis ensuite
il est parti de chez lui en voiture il a
eu un accident de voiture juste à côté
de l'école et c'est à ce moment là qu'il
est sorti de sa voiture des policiers
ont tenté de l'interpeller à ce moment
là mais il leur a tiré dessus et ils ont
été blessés il est ensuite rentré dans
l'école que vous voyez derrière moi et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il s'est
barricadé dans une classe en particulier
dans une classe où il a tué donc dix
neuf enfants et deux adultes
la ville est vraiment sous le choc j'ai
pu discuter avec des habitants qui
habite juste à quelques mètres de
l'école est vraiment il n'avait jamais
imaginé voir quelque chose pareille
arrive et dans cette petite ville c'est
une ville de 16 mille habitants on est
ici dans le texas rural ou mises à part
quelques problèmes avec la frontière
mexicaine des problèmes de trafic de
drogue de trafic humain la ville la vie
ici est plutôt est plutôt calme merci
pierrick et joe biden donc doit se
rendre sur place là où vous vous trouvez
donc à elles deux au texas dès ce
week-end on va écouter le président
américain qui justement on demande à
transformer cette douleur en acte
c'était hier soir dans la nuit juste
après la tuerie
pourquoi acceptons-nous de vivre avec
ces carnages pourquoi continuons-nous a
laissé faire oui pour l'amour de dieu
notre courage d'y faire face et de tenir
tête aux lobbies
il est temps de transformer cette
douleur en actes pour chaque parent pour
chaque citoyen nous devons faire
comprendre à tous les élus de ce pays
qu'il est temps d'agir
charlotte reconquis où il l'a dit à
nouveau job hayden ça n'arrive nulle
part ailleurs il faut transformer
effectivement cet homo sio cette émotion
en acte on a vu dans le sujet on se
souvient des larmes de barack obama
depuis dix ans rien ne change pour quoi
parce que les institutions ne donne pas
pouvoir à l'état fédéral de changer
beaucoup de choses déjà ça c'est une
première un premier élément important
les états fédérés conserve une marge de
manoeuvre importante sur la protection
de ce second amendement et ses
dispositions particulières et puis parce
que comme c'était évoquez dans votre
reportage les équilibres partisans et
politiques n'ont pas non plus donné
l'espace politique à barack obama est
aujourd'hui à joe biden je pense de
manoeuvrer en faveur d'une plus grande
d'un plus grand encadrement du droit des
armes il ya de la volonté politique de
la part de joe biden mais une marge de
manoeuvre faible c'est comme ça qu'on
pourrait le résumer il faut quand même
rappeler que même la volonté politique
elle porte sur l'encadrement de l'accès
et de l'usagé des armes à pas sur une
interdiction totale du droit des armes
comme on pourrait l'imaginer l'imaginé
si donc de toutes façons même la volonté
politique elle est relativement modérée
par rapport à nos propres standards sur
un débat comme des armes à feu c'est ça
qui paraît assez incroyable alexandre
mains d'al vous qui avez suivi de
nombreux trump heist pour votre livre
ils soutiennent eux bien sûr la vente
libre d'armes à feu ils disent toujours
c'est toujours le même discours que ce
ne sont pas les armes ce sont ceux qui
utilisent les armes donc en fait il faut
armer les instituteurs armée en fait il
faut y arriver que les plus extrémistes
disons des gens qui étaient proulx armes
à feu étaient plutôt critique sur trump
à ce que trump avait quand même engagé
plus qu'obama s'est tellement des
réformes qui n'aimait pas par exemple
interdiction du mbam stocks une espèce
de dispositifs plastique à ressorts qui
permet de transformer une arme semi
automatique en armes automatiques si
vous souvenez de la tuerie peut-être du
mandala bay hôtel à las vegas savez
d'interdît par parts rams avaient été
très mal vécue il avait été ensuite
approuver d'ailleurs par la nra c'est
sur cette interdiction ce qu'on présente
toujours en france la nra comme étant là
une association de semis fascistes
sont favorables
à d'autres associations pro armes à feu
aux états unis qui elles sont
constituées en glisse et qui sont
beaucoup plus extrémiste que la nra la
nra passe chez les gens les plus
extrémistes pour des centristes des
vilains voilà c'est peut-être des
lobbyistes de washington et point c'est
tout c'est en tout cas ce que vous avez
rencontré qu'on croyait cette liberté
pardonnez moi oui tout à fait à ses
quelque chose qui ne comprenaient pas
quand tu voyais un français pour eux
c'est aussi fondamental qu'est la
liberté d'expression c'est d'ailleurs
ces concerné le justifie il dit on
pourrait pas défendre notre liberté
d'expression si on n'avait pas notre
liberté de porter une arme sur nous pour
la défendre sabrina inventa seul vous
avez rejoint bonsoir à vous journalistes
réalisatrice franco américaine l'état du
texas contre mélissa et puis les armes
de la colère de documentaires qu'on peut
retrouver sur my canal alors on se
souvient de ces images peut-être que
vous avez suivi ces jeunes parce que
effectivement alexandre mende elle parle
de ses tropismes il y avait ces jeunes
après cette tuerie à parkland en flore
et notamment cette jeune fille on se
souvient de la mobilisation se souvient
de son discours qui était extrêmement
fort ils sont allés jusqu'au congrès et
ça n'a rien donné donc effectivement
cette société américaine est totalement
fracturé sur cette question donc on se
souvient des magasins à l'aise si
vivement lendemain de parkland qui avec
avait insufflé en fait un espoir
incroyable mouvement pas possible comme
à chaque fois vraiment mais là on est
qu'il y ait l'appel de militants sous
ces jeunes qui qui s'étaient unis qui
voulaient bien aller dans les urnes et
enfin vraiment réclamer un changement
alors où ils ont quand même réussi
quelques paramètres baydan au pouvoir
parce qu'ils ont vraiment réussi à faire
voter les gens en masse
maintenant aujourd'hui il ne reste plus
grand chose quoi on à la mairie que la
mecque n'a jamais été aussi autant armée
depuis le vide on va les gens qu'ils
sont armés en masse
aujourd'hui on voit les femmes qui
s'arme on voit les afro-américains qui
s'arme enfin on va dire que que tout ça
est un peu été réduits à néant or
justement en regardant les statistiques
le nombre de morts par armes à feu n'a
jamais autant augmenté qu'en 2020 donc
2020 c'était il ya deux ans vingt mille
homicide en douze mois un taux
d'homicides de 6,1 pour cent mille
habitants en europe pour faire une
comparaison france royaume uni allemagne
c'est un taux entre 1 et 1,5 donc ces
cinq à six fois moins qu'aux états unis
et depuis le début de l'année il ya déjà
eu deux cent douze matches yuting masse
shooting ça veut dire les tueries dans
lequel il ya plus de 4 personnes 4
victimes eric nissan on vous retrouve
tout de suite à washington il ya ce
fameux deuxième amendement alors
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer
pourquoi ce deuxième amendement de la
constitution qui date de 10 791 pourquoi
est il aussi est sacré pourquoi comme
vient de le dire alexandre vindelle
liberté de port d'armes ça rime avec
liberté d'expression aux états unis
alors il faut comprendre
d'emblée que cette fameuse deuxième
amendement n'était jamais considéré
comme a comme une telle force juridique
avant l'année 2008 c'est seulement en
2008 que le cour suprême des etats unis
a à donner dans une décision
qui s'appelait
contre la ville de washington la
capitale que il faut 2 pour donner une
interprétation beaucoup plus littéral
qui était pensé avant et c'est ça qui
était vraiment radical qui a beaucoup
changé la conception de la jurisprudence
et depuis c'était vraiment cette avenue
en a une
presque une clé politique surtout pour
les républicains de pousser pousser pour
cette conception d'une très forte
deuxième amendement qui était jamais
considéré comme ça avant a presque comme
une religion et même pour tous les juges
tous les juristes 7
c'est ça doit être le première chose
qu'il se prononce avec le il faut aussi
être contre l'avortement mais c'est très
très lié il faut comprendre ça et ça
c'est devenu quelque chose très clé dans
la partie républicaine et c'est pour ça
que tu législation toute tentative
sont bloqués non seulement du point de
vue juridique mais du point de vue
politique en voit dans les législatures
des zetas et les états républicaine qui
bloque tout et et dont le sénat
américain c'est la même chose c'est les
républicains et pour le président c'est
très très dur de lutter contre ça même
trempe il a vraiment rien essayer dès
qu'il a compris que la partie où sera
contre lui il a tout il a dû delachet et
est en voie il y à beaucoup des fonds de
ces questions d'argent aussi lâchement
rail fo l'association donne énormément
d'argent au parti républicain nos
politiciens et avait cessé d'augmenter
pendant les années et voilà la situation
qui existe aujourd'hui et charlotte hors
cac orco qui ont c'est vrai que on voit
qu'il ya vraiment une strate sujet
clivant entre démocrates et républicains
un peu comme l'avortement selon le droit
à l'avortement entre les deux et de
tendances politiques seulement 20% des
électeurs républicains sont favorables à
une restriction du port d'armes et ils
sont 81% chez les démocrates donc c'est
un sujet aussi clivant que l'avortement
mais ce qui interroge c'est que même
dans les états plutôt démocrates aux
états unis il y en a qu'une dizaine qui
ont pris vraiment des mesures de
régulation de ces ports d'armes donc
comme si en fait depuis 20 ans même les
démocrates finalement n'ont pas le
courage de
de réguler des armes alors qu'ils le
souhaitent il ya plusieurs éléments ya
effectivement une question
politique est une question culturelle
qui se superposent l'une à l'autre et il
faut ajouter pour comprendre vraiment la
question à ce que ce qui vient d'être
dit que le surmonte amendement
initialement c'est un amendement qui
permet aux citoyens de se défendre
contre la possible tyranides de l'état
et c'est très très important dans la
culture américaine de comprendre que les
américains ne veulent absolument pas que
l'état intervienne dans leur vie privée
et ils veulent pouvoir s'en défendant
c'est de là que vient le second
amendement qui a effectivement été
renforcée en 2008 avec une décision de
la cour suprême donc ça explique que
même les démocrates sont très attachés à
ce droit individuel et à cette liberté
individuelle la liberté de se défendre
la liberté de défendre éventuellement sa
propriété où sa famille ou ses voisins
la légitime défense et c'est donc donc
il ya vraiment un jeu politique et
culturelle qui ce qui s'entremêlent mais
il ya un certain nombre de réactions on
va écouter tout de suite celle de steve
kerr l'entraîneur des golden state
warriors des réactions comme ça eh bien
on en a beaucoup après ce type après
cette tuerie ont l'écoutent
à
ce cours
il ya 19 enfants qui ont été tués c'est
un cliché depuis alexandre e mendel
votre réaction justement est ce que il
pas particulièrement politique steve
kerr miliana de nombreuses des ragondins
ça c'est à chaque fusillade on vous sort
de trois stars dont j'attends tom hanks
qui va se rouler par terre et on y
sentait pas bien parce que ils visent un
peu à l'européenne il s'adresse à des
gens des villes des démocrates pardon
parler comme ça mais c'est le cas je
peux vous dire que ce que raconte cet
homme au fin fond du kansas tout le
monde s'en fiche et autexas aujourd'hui
non je ne dis pas que les américains ne
font pas de deuil au texas qui quand
même pas l'état le plus permissif sur le
l'acquisition d'armes contrairement à
une légende contrairement à une légende
il n'y a pas loupé paris dakar et
l'internât pas l'open carrie au texas
est plus basse que voulait aller dans
des états vraiment permis si vous allez
en caroline du nord en caroline du sud
là vous voyez en arizona quand même des
texans ont déménagé dans certains états
qui qui voit là non ses rangs cancer
missiles mais là je veux quand même
souligner quelque chose qui est très
européen chez nous c'est qu'on regarde
ça à nous avec nos yeux d'européens
scandalisé et on n'estime pas et je vous
rejoins tout à fait là dessus que c'est
dans la culture américaine que même on
rencontre des démocrates qui nous
explique que c'est un égalisateur le
fait de pouvoir porter une arme à feu
les régulations du port de leurs marais
à le relire
mais je vous explique la régulation vous
venez avec une carte de bibliothèque à
wal mart et voilà la différence entre le
entre le un état et un autre c'est qu'on
voit là votre écoute et tout de suite
greg abbott justement en direct en deux
du texas et le gouverneur du texas un
républicain
qui abat sa grand mère dans le visage il
faut qu'il le que le mal sur l'âge
d'aller dans son coeur
mais c'est beaucoup moins bien pire
encore
d'abattre des enfants
voir dans cet état quelqu'un qui serait
tuer des enfants dans les écoles
parce que nous sommes ravis d'avoir des
enfants dieu nous l'a enseigné
il rit
il
y ait l'air
et d'un cadeau
les parents peuvent accepter recevoir
chaque jour
les parents
qui ont reçu ce cadeau mais ce qu'on
leur a pris ce cadeau on leur a volé ce
cadeau
c'est un fou qui leur a volé ce cadeau
quelques jours auparavant
avant hier
quand ces enfants
étaient à l'école
certains d'entrés certains d'entre eux
plutôt garder des prix pour pouvoir
accueillir les gens
mais ces enfants n'iront plus à l'école
valdé été bouleversée jusqu'au plus
profond de nous mêmes des familles ont
été brisées et des choeurs ont été
brisées pour l'éternité au texte tous
les texans
sont en dedans avec les gens du vin
dribbles et
oui les gens ont des raisons d'être en
colère
par rapport à ce qui se produit
parce que des tragédies comme celle ci
vont déchirer le coeur même de la
communauté notre travail c'est de
s'assurer que cette communauté ne soient
déchirées mardi l'examen doit
solidariser pour des femmes qui m'a
touché parce ce que fera jeudi
horrifique ce dont ils ont besoin plus
que jamais c'est de l'amour
ils ont besoin
d'être conforté
leurs compatriotes qu'ils soient du
texas où du reste des états unis
on doit assister sur une chose
que vous savez tous
[Musique]
la réalité tout aussi horrible que ce
qui est arrivé ça aurait pu être
la raison pour laquelle sympa été pire
c'est parce que
les
agents de la police ont agi comme il est
il mais ils ont été très courageux
ils ont été à la rencontre de ce tireur
pour sauver des linéaires
c'est une amérique 2
et à leur rapidité
parce qu'ils sont arrivés rapidement
qu'ils ont pu courir est éliminé pour ce
tireur ils ont été en mesure de sauver
des vies
malheureusement ça n'était pas suffisant
mais je devrai m'assurer
que chacun d'entre vous
se rend compte que les policiers et les
groupes qui ont participé
à ce processus
les rangers du texas
comment ces enquêtes sont soutenus par
le département des recettes de la
sécurité publique par l'acquisition et
pénales
gbps et ses différents services
le soutien aux survivants du dps
également par le service et gestion des
urgences le fiel nombreux partenaires et
les nombreux services qui s'y rattachent
ainsi que les frontaliers agents
frontaliers ainsi qu'un grand nombre
d'autres ciels
le
département de valdès
la pince les districts scolaires et
baldé maire
les juges de quitter les centres de
formation les
différents services de ce public et la
police et les pompiers de san antonio
je voudrais vous parler d'un certain
nombre de frais qui se sont prenait on a
mis beaucoup de choses certaines sont
réelles d'autres ne sont pas
je veux donner les meilleures
informations qu'on a pour le moment il
fallait comprendre que c'est une enquête
qui se poursuit
et très souvent on découvrait alors des
faits nouveaux au fur et à mesure que
l'enquêté se poursuit tout d'abord que
c'est un produit dont
le tireur
sur le visage de saint lambert elle a
contacté la police il s'est enfui et
puis il a eu un accident juste en dehors
de l'école primaire il a écrasé son
véhicule
servette heures sont se sont approchés
du tireur à ce moment dame
le tireur est entré par une porte
arrière il est passé par bien
l'aube il est entré dans une salle de
classe
vous êtes entré dans cette classe était
relié à une autre classe
les frontaliers
il est agent
de dps et d'autres sont arrivés
sur place et
l'un des agents à tulle
les rangers du texas pour suivre cette
en tête avec l'aide de police fédérale
d'états et locales nous savons
actuellement
que 19 enfants
19 enfants
ont péri
deux enseignants
ont péri également
en doute
[Musique]
il y a dix sept personnes qui ont été
blessées
mais ses blessures ne devrait pas
entraîner
compromettre le pronostic vital tous les
membres des familles
de ces enfants de ces enseignants ont
été contactées et on les a informé la
situation
les officiers travail avec les parents
pour s'assurer que il eût pu
s'identifier dans enfin les parents
doivent contacter le service des
victimes du comté de fairfax il y a des
parents qui
n'ont pas encore réussi à entrer en
communication
et nous invitons tous les parents nous
les encourageons à
contacter le service des victimes du
comté de faire face
le tireur avait 18 ans
et ne souhaitait plus l'école paraît-il
ont paraît il n'avait pas d'antécédents
judiciaires rennes et tours peut-être
qu'ils avaient investie et je lis fier
en tant que j'ai vu ni nous n'avons pas
encore déterminé
il ne m'avait pas d'épisode de maladie
mentale c'est un ar 15
avec 23 rhin de munitions une seule arme
il n'y a pas eu de signes significatifs
avant coureur à part ce que je vais vous
dire
actuellement la seule information et
l'ondé tenez à l'avance
été postée par le tireur sur facebook on
sait l'entourent de 30 minutes
avant qu'il parvienne à l'école alors le
premier poste était
portée enfin le disait suzy je vais
tirer sur ma grand mère le deuxième
poste
10 et j'ai tiré sur ma grand mère ma
grand mère le troisième poste peut-être
même pas quinze minutes avant d'arriver
à l'école et et je vais tirer dans une
école primaire
je les dis
je dis que
pendant le match ac pendant les tirs
en plus des écoliers et des enseignants
il y avait trois agents qui ont été
blessés qui sont en bonne condition
un adjoint chérif
a perdu sa fille
à cette école
avant de venir ici nous avons eu une
longue discussion avec les différents
agents des différentes forces avec des
officiels avec des élus avec des
personnes de la communauté j'ai demandé
au shérif et adolphe train de l'ancienne
carrière de questions nous avons eu les
mêmes réponses du shérif que du maire un
du val d
la question était
calé problème
ils ont été très direct et ils ont
insisté ils ont des
problèmes de santé mentale
au sein du valais et ils ont fourni des
détails sur l'ampleur
de défis et qu'ils affrontent au sein de
la communauté le besoin de soutien à la
santé mentale dans cette région je
voudrais m'assurer que tout le monde
comprenne bien
il y à des services qui sont disponibles
dès maintenant
et nous allons préciser une chose par la
suite
à la suite de cette tragédie
quand quelque chose de choquant
d'extraordinaire et d' épouvantable
comme ceci intervient
il y as besoin pressant pour que toutes
les personnes affectées se tourner vers
les services de santé mentale
je ne serai pas insister davantage en
dix ans et jeudi avec un sens d'urgence
que chacun au sein des communautés je
veux vraiment dire chacun d'entre nous
les victimes
[Musique]
familles
les policiers l'ensemble de la
communauté
est bouleversé choqué par cet événement
il ya des blessures physiques
des policiers mais ça ça va guérir dans
quelques jours
les blessures mental et psychologique
pendant beaucoup plus de temps à guérir
l'état du texas travaille avec les
agents chez les officiers locaux et
fédéraux nous serons ici longtemps pour
le long terme
un point important sur lequel nous
allons justesse et de s'assurer que
chacun au sein de cette communauté et
axes et l'axé dont il a besoin aussi
longtemps qu'il en aura besoin pour
traiter les conséquences mentales et
psychologiques ils peuvent abriter
les différentes agences
je m'assurerai que les services
d'urgence
des services
augmentant les services pour survivants
sont disponibles à tous niveaux y
compris le centre de ressources
familiales du vin des
écoles aussi pour peuvent être sont
accessibles et peuvent fournir des
services globaux pour les familles qui
ont été touchés
le consortium a santé mentale des
enfants du texas
qui a été créée en 2019 indisponibles le
centre blue bird
peut fournir des services pour lundi
vers l'est la commission des services du
texas est aussi disponible
lui fournir des services mon agence des
services scolaires fournir des services
supplémentaires les services de sécurité
peuvent semer
des force de répulsion élèves pays je
peux aussi fournir des services
psychologiques pour les policiers
pour les officiers il est très important
pour eux de s'exprimer et d'obtenir ce
subtil
aussi le service de parcs et et le
service et survivant à toute une palette
de services qui soient à la disposition
des survivants de l'ensemble de la
communauté
on m'a donné un
un numéro de téléphone que je vais vous
donner il s'agit du parc et
8,3
0278 de
9,1 si
je maintenant donner la parole aux à
l'adjoint au gouverneur
c'est patrick
le lieutenant gouverneur plus excusez
moi
mais revient attendre greg abbott donc
au gouverneur du texas on ne savait il
n'y avait pas de signes avant coureurs
at il dit sur ce fameux tueur de 18 ans
sauf sur facebook où il est dit sur
facebook il avait tué sa grand mère
après avoir dit qu'il avait tué sa
grand-mère qui ensuite il allait
effectivement effectuer une tuerie dans
cette école élémentaire sabrina vente à
salifou de redonner un petit peu de
contexte sur qui justement et greg
abbott pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
ce gouverneur du texas public induit
fort très partisan justement de cette
liberté du port d'armes il a même
facilité lusage du port d'armes au texas
et il accueille d'ailleurs la convention
de la nrpt est donc le fameux lobby
programme ce week-end donc il est en
campagne
oui il est en campagne il a d'ailleurs
besoin du vote latino il n'a pas
vraiment
les latinos derrière lui il faut quand
même signaler c'est assez compliqué pour
plein de raisons et je ne pense pas que
ce qui s'est passé là va vraiment
l'aider mais vous voyez vous l'avez
entendu il justifie de tous bien
évidemment il n'y avait pas de signes
avant-coureurs il n'aurait pas pu le
savoir alors qu'il y avait peu tous
postés sur facebook et bien évidemment
si tout le monde était plus armés et
bien ce genre de choses ne se seraient
pas passées c'est exactement ça le le
discours en fait et ça c'est le discours
des républicains
donc charlotte qu'aux clients on
retrouve ce qu'on entend c'est que bon
il dit y avait pas de signes
avant-coureurs et avait pas de phase de
moyens d'imaginer qu'il avait les
preuves de santé mentale à part le fait
qu'il avait annoncé ce meurtre vous
venez de le rappeler et il a dit quand
même au début c'est un fou c'est l'acte
d'un fou mais ça permet pas de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
pourquoi ça se reproduit sans cesse
c'est pas l'acte juste d'un fou il ya
des rapports de l'est si l ue l'american
civil liberties union qui montrent par
exemple que dans la plupart des
établissements scolaires il ya plus
d'assistantes sociales et à plus de
psychologues il ya plus de conseillers
d'orientation méga d'apprendre mais y'a
bcp police et yada surveillance et c'est
donc le ce jeune du lycée voisin il
poste des armes il est fasciné par les
armes à feu mais il n'ya pas
d'assistance psychologique
il ya une loi et depuis 1993 qui
interdit aux ministères de la santé de
faire des recherches qui pourraient
conduire à
avoir des résultats négatifs sur les
faits d armes à feu dans la société
américaine sous les 10 km en vente il ya
un tas de lois et de politiques
publiques comme ça qui crée les
conditions pour que ce genre de drame
entre guillemets se produise alexandre
vindelle en tout cas il ne parle pas de
la lézarde là on est d'accord avec vous
mais on est quand même sur la caricature
sur sur le texas parce que en effet on
imagine tous comme des cow boys avec
n'ya pas d'open carrie déjà
mais la californie l'état le plus
restrictifs en matière de port d'armes
c'est quand même l'endroit où il ya eu
le plus de matchs shooting l'année
dernière et c'est je crois que ça compte
même pour 40 % de tous les goûts mais
c'est plus grand que c'était en fait pas
de corrélation entre la régulation des
armes à feu et le nombre de matchs
footing jeudi juste jeudi jusqu'à 50
d'abstention à 50% 50% des mages
shooting comme d'études des massacres
des des tueries sont quand même effectué
par des gens qui n'ont pas procédé à un
achat légale d'armes c'est à dire qu'il
qui l'ont qu'ils ont eue sur un deuxième
circuit plus en plus ce qu'on appelle
les
gauchos aux états unis on ne vous
demande même pas votre carte il n'y a
pas de carte d'identité mais on vous
demande pas de justifier de votre
identité ça passe de la maison qui se
sont procuré l'arme d'acheter légalement
par leurs parents pas bien joué alors
après on parle de ce jeune homme qui est
allé tuer et c'est bon mais s'il fallait
piste et tous les loosers fait signer et
cetera par tel ou tel tenait aux états
unis on n'en finirait pas je suis désolé
dans l'est il faut aussi s'interroger
sur pourquoi l'amérique plutôt que de
s'interroger sur les âmes créer des gens
comme comme comme ce type qui est venu
ouvrir le feu sur des gamins parce que
ces gens-là ils baignent dans l'idée
qu'il faut réussir qu'il faut avoir sa
piscine deux pick-up et cetera qu'il
faut séduire comme dans les séries
netflix et deviennent cinglé parce
qu'ils n'y arrivent pas et c'est comme
ça qu'ils se c'est une fabrice on a l
axe ce sont des déserts ils se sourient
dans une fabrique de désespéré qui
s'appelle l'amérique profonde et
réglisse et ce que nous avons la même
chose excusez moi mais en france et nous
n'avons pas ce genre dont on a des gens
qui attaquent aux classes justement nous
n'avons pas d'armes et donc c'est ça un
peu la grosse grenade alors vous
connaissez peut-être alors je sais pas
si c'est
bien sûr parce que je veux dire on est
encore extrêmement régulé en france du
dessert il ya des accidents de chasse
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous aurions
exactement la même chose si jamais nous
avions là vous voulez vous procurer en
france une arme illégalement ce serait
plus compliqué qu aux etats-unis même si
vraiment vous voulez vous en procurer où
nous vous la procurer eric l'isan
puisque vous êtes l'américain de ce
plateau est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
une corrélation vous entre le contrôle
ou l'absence de contrôle justement des
armes à feu et les masses shooting
alors il faut comprendre d'abord qu'une
grande majorité des américains soutient
lé contrôle des armes ça veut dire ils
sont pas radical le gouverneur de textes
c'est une radicale sur sept sujets cette
recherche à la fois être qu'à brouiller
clown à il faut dire la vérité sur lui
n'est pas le seul mais c'est là son
pouvoir cc lacq parce que les militants
de son parti réclame ça mais c'est pas
vraiment la position des majorité des
américains nous verrons déjà dans le
texte ce oui c'est un peu différent il y
as legrand de l'action en novembre buts
contre better off nous verrons si ça
joue le rôle mais le problème de la
régulation des armes c'est le même
problème convoi dont presque toutes les
avenues de la gouvernance américain
contemporaine c'est que c'est la
minorité les américains peuvent imposer
leur désir sur la majorité et ils ont
des revenus très forte à cette façon
d'exploiter les choses et en voit les
conséquences
les etats unis aujourd'hui c'est le seul
pays du monde où il y à ces massacres
comme ça qu'ils seraient produisent tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
dans les écoles mais pas seulement dans
les écoles alors donc et voilà le vrai
problème que peut faire joe biden pour
conclure justement cette émission
charlotte recopions
cotillons
joe biden y va il va faire ce qu'il peut
mais quand on dit les américains sont
favorables à un contrôle des amis sont
favorables à certaines mesures
consensuelles comme les backgrounds ex
dont 80 important que les américains
voudraient un contrôle sur ce qu'ils
achètent les armes c'est à dire sur le
profil des personnes qui ont gâché sert
par exemple
peut-être que ça peut passer peut-être
que ça peut passer de restreindre
l'accès aux personnes qui ont des
problèmes de santé mentale mais quand on
va sur d'autres mesures de type
interdiction des armes d'assaut ou des
armes de guerre quand on va sur des
propositions comme un fichier national
des détenteurs et un registre des
détenteurs d'armes etc là il ya de très
fortes oppositions et les américains
possesseurs d'armes sont très très actif
politiquement très mobilisés ils
écrivent à leur élu tout le temps ils
sont investis à la nrf il s'investit
dans les campagnes électorales et donc
c'est pas impossible donc là c'est
l'émotion les élus bougent qu'ils sont
plus investis en fait ceux qui veulent
justement cette liberté à des armes que
les autres peut-être qu'ils pèsent
davantage pour ce qui est du parti
républicain tout ce qui est du parti
démocrate en effet que les
manifestations suffisent pas bon je
reviens votre question est ce que bill
donne peut faire quelque chose non
d'autant qu'il va perdre les élections
prochaines en dents dans six mois il
valait vers sèchement 6 non pas sur la
question de larmes parce que je suis
désolé le deuil sera passé mais sur la
question de l'inflation les américains
sont pas tellement différents de nous ce
sujet là ils vont voter parce qu'ils ont
ils ont peuvent plus de payer trop cher
voir sabrina van tassel il peut faire
quelque chose durbanais il a dit qu'il
allait essayer quillivant l'action mais
ils disent tous ça en fait obama a dit
ça dit la même chose en fait à chaque
fois ils s'opposent en fait à la loi des
états qui ont qui d'ailleurs le disait à
juste titre le texas n'est pas le pire
en matière d'armes l'arizona par exemple
a fait voter la loi sanctuaire larry zen
l'arizona a carrément décrété que s'il
n'obéissait pas à l'état fédéral et
qu'il ferait ce qu'ils veulent en
matière d'art et c'est carrément fins
etc est carrément quelque chose qui
n'est qui n'est pas légal mais ils ont
dit qu'ils le feraient ce qu'en fait il
ça va être très très très dur pour by
donne en tout cas de faire quoi que ce
soit sera plutôt à chaque état de faire
quelque chose et puis pour retirer un
amendement c'est très complexe il faut
deux tiers du de la chambre des
représentants deux tiers du sénat 38 est
à d'accord ils les auront ils les auront
jamais dans l'histoire américaine il ya
qu un seul amendement qui a été retirée
comme ça c'est celui sur la prohibition
de l'alcool et c'est tout et c'est un
mot de conclusion à ce qui pourrait par
exemple prend un règlement fédéral baden
qui puisse au moins régulé le profil de
ceux qui achètent des armes
très vite ça sera lutte ce sera un lieu
très très difficile pour lui je crois
qu'il est le mieux placé personnellement
à à cause de ses convictions propres lui
même que tout autre président mais la
tâche devant lui avec le senate est très
très lourde mais je crois que pour lui
c'est quelque chose personnelle il va
essayer mais s'il var et s'ils
réussissent à sera là vraiment
incroyable merci beaucoup et réquista
and d'avoir été avec nous en duplex de
washington experts juridiques ancien
procureur fédéral américain merci
s'abonnant volta seul journaliste
réalisatrice franco américaine mercy
avoue alexandre romain d'elle j'en aï
spécialiste des états unis et puis merci
à vous chers lecteurs coquillon merci à
vous tous deux heures suivi est avec 900
français
[Musique]